I'M BORIS SANCHEZ.G, BORIS.
M
AND, AN TAL
NING.
RUSSIA'S WARUKRAT TE
OOLLEDINAK
CAPITAL  COURSE.
ARING FOR  ASSAUN E N PARTE ANNP
MINISTER BOR THE
DI MILITARY EQUIPMENT THAT
E.
HNURPRIS
TOW THE NITED KINGDOO OVIDE
E.
>> BUTKRVEITM DOES N H
PEOPE, AMUST BTAKEN ME RE HEAD E
SAW N OF LR E'S ALE E CARNE
RD'VE SEENN LY FACY RRORIZING PG
FOR THEIR SOVERENTY, BUT EY'RE
WIE
PART OF THE COUNTRHAVE B TO STAY
HOMENTIL 6:00 A.M. LOC TIME
TO THE
THE TASIAN
CKS.AND WE ARE GTI REPF NEW MISL
DE BY . VGENERAL,S WE
SIR  UKRAINE.CNN CORRESPONDENT K
HISTORY.THIS GAL A
TO  WT WE KNOING
>> Repor C
GOOD MORNING.
WE PLANNIN
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT, ED, IN
ONSIBLE AL RUSSIA'S
ACCORDING TO WESTERN OIC HAS FOT
ND
NTOF
ATIGN THRIE  ION IN THE SYRIAN C
FLTEATN. THESEL
ANCONVOYUSSIANT HAWHAT DO YOU M
JUT OF KHARKIV, VERY CLOSEHE RUG
SOUTH, I B
IA AS OF IT,ED UP
TH REGION, SOU
OF ADVANCE O ADVANCE TO EXPAND L
AND IT'S EXPECTED THAT THA
WHERIAG TO TRYPUSHNIANNES.O  MTE
ING RTCERN N FORCESLE OVEHEBED
ES NEW
PE>> PHIL BLACK. S ALL THE NEW
INFORMYOU.
ENCOURAGENISJO
REUKNSON MADE P KY
MET WITHELCOESITAT MEALLTOINE.
G IN KYIV, THES SOMBER AAS IT DE
D KE
TO N
HE BROUGITF WHAT
G OFRIGUARANTEE, OF UKRAINE'BT .
NGR THEYUT HE HER WORLD LEHAD  E
UKRAINIANS, THEY HAT THE VIS
B UE S RUSSOF THE
STEAM.
EVENAL
JUST TS
WILL GLOBAL
>> NEMA,HA SO MU> IONS REECYAYM
THEIR COUNTRY SIT OF RUSSIA'S I
UKRAINE.O TIRINO ITHHA Y
MUCH.
I K N  TIS ALARMER, 7.1 LE AR,
CHOOSIO STAYAT
IS YOUR GREATEST CONCERN FOR TH
LEAVG COUNTRIES.
ARE IN E COUNY WHER
WITH THESO SURTH THEIR NEEDS.TH,
ANTHESE TOESEY T INSIDE. OF THE
AR PLACE.
LEE
COUNY,EAVE TGHSTERN BORDERHE, AS
YOU HAAIINOUR
VEUKRAINE.
NO UKRAINIO Y ONCOUNTRIES ALL OD